you know how many virgin chicks I've met
that I actually believe because you know
you also get the ones that say they are
but are super
argumentative and disagreeable so you
know a virgin isn't even spiteful virgin
isn't even ideal a 4% of women are
virgins on their wedding days that still
counts for the argumentative virgins the
fat virgins this isn't what men want
okay but anyways out of thousands of
interviews do you know how many I found
one
one and you can't even tell me that
we're picking for special chicks no
Andrew no Andrew this is the culture
this is the new world more there are
more only fans models than teachers now